you know on the first day of medical
school
uh we started the dissection of a
cadaver in the class called anatomy lab
and so in a way we were kind of thrown
right in there in the beginning like
this is the end of the human story you
know understand this and then we sort of
backed up to the beginning with
embryology and reproduction and stuff so
it's kind of like we got and i got
thrown into that right right away right
in the beginning kind of like here's a
dead body now start cutting it apart and
learn the name and function of
absolutely every bit of flesh how did
that change you that first
experience with the cold honesty of
human biology right that's exactly what
it was it's cold honesty about the kind
of the story of each individual human
body it has an end and that's it
um i think that well
actually before the end of that first
day so what we did on that first day was
study the superficial muscles of the
back like the lats or latismus dorsey
and some other muscles you know we cut
through the skin of the back my cadaver
was laying face down on this metal
gurney we pulled back the kind of
plastic sheets that would keep him moist
for the next four months as we dissected
him
cut through the skin on his back and
then started dissecting through the
superficial muscles of the back and that
was really all we saw that first day
we didn't get any deeper didn't enter
the abdominal or
chest cavity to see internal organs but
i was so fascinated with this sort of
behind the scenes look at how things
work in the body how you move your arms
how you arch your back you know these
are the muscles that do it
that i decided i wanted to donate my own
body for the same purpose um so i made
that decision literally before the end
of that first day of class and i i'm
still sticking to it so someday there
will be a medical student
that can
watch and listen to this podcast
and while dissecting your body it could
happen they might not know that that
person they're listening to on the
podcast will be the carcass in front of
them but uh like we don't we never learn
the universe will know the universe and
they will acknowledge
the irony or the humor the absurdity of
that the universe will chuckle but the
medical student won't know
because they never as i did not learn
any uh you know personal information
about the person
only what i could glean from looking
inside him which actually tells you
quite a bit i knew he was a smoker i
knew he had coronary artery disease you
know you get a a window into i knew he
was overweight you get a window into
people's lives just by looking in there
in their bodies after death other other
um cadavers in the lab not my own
or i shared one with three other
students but other cadavers some had you
know metal joints like a knee
replacement some had a kidney missing so
they probably and we could tell it was
surgically removed not that he was born
with one
uh and we could tell that he probably
had a kidney tumor or cancer that was
removed so you do get an insight into
people's lives from
you know picking them apart after
they're dead but you don't know their
name or what podcast they've been on
so the as the book title says unseen
body
so it it tells
some kind of story of your life
so it does capture the decisions you've
made in your life the things you've done
that might be kind of secret
to that person and maybe to a few others
that knew
him or her well
it's so fascinating so
what kind of things can it reveal like
what kind of choices in terms of the
injuries
the
the the catastrophic events
the
lifestyle choices of smoking and diet
and all those kinds of things what what
what what can you see what kind of
history can you see about the human
before you
so all those things you mentioned are
things you can see you can you know take
the skin for example right most things
that happen to us
leave a mark uh you know as i say a kind
of a story written in the language of
scar where it tells you injuries you've
had and same thing with animals you know
i've
i've seen deer hides that have marks
that look like they were made by maybe a
barbed wire fence something like that
you can tell
you know you sometimes it's conjecture
but you can sort of imagine what might
have happened to cause that perhaps you
know two bucks were fighting and one got
injured with an antler um and the same
with humans you know i have scars on my
body and when i
notice them i remember what happened you
know i
got a big cut on my hand when i was 13
and it's still there and i
remember what happened uh you know every
time i look at it and so in that way
only i might know that story but other
people you know when they dissect me and
notice the same scars they can kind of
it can fire their imagination as my
cadaver you know did for me they know
that there is a story there that's such
an interesting way that the skin does
tell a story
uh with both tattoos and scars
right
even the fun you've had and some of the
damage you've done right and even when i
when i evaluate a patient i can use
scars to help me make medical decisions
so for instance someone that comes in
with abdominal pain into the emergency
room you can see scars on their abdomen
that tell you about you know the past
kind of activities of a surgeon perhaps
i know i recognize the scars that are
left when someone has their gallbladder
removed the scars when someone has their
appendix removed when maybe when
someone's had a hysterectomy and that
can tell you
what it might be or what it isn't you
know if someone doesn't have an appendix
their abdominal pain is not appendicitis
end of story so in that way
i'm sort of looking at these the the
tracks or the footprints of past
surgeries to tell me what what might and
might not be the cause of this patient's
abdominal pain which is kind of my main
job
you